allemagne de l'est et suisse les deux
nations qui ont bénéficié de ces cette
première soirée de sur le vélodrome de
san cristóbal à ce championnat du monde
cycliste les médailles françaises se
font rares en fait une autre course
poursuite vient de commencer une chasse
dont carlos et le gibier
il était le seul à pouvoir s'en douter
heureux hasard de l'époque le directeur
de l'équipe de france était un ancien
des services spéciaux quelques mois
avant l'épreuve sportive à berlin un ex
collègue lui avait tenu une curieuse
conversation et à un moment donné il m'a
dit il y a le cas carlos est ce que le
cas échéant tu accepterais de nous aider
ma réponse a été oui mais c'est tout
cinq agents français traquent le célèbre
terroriste sur ses terres parmi eux un
certain max philippe rondot de son vrai
nom il guette tout signe que pourrait
donner carlos à son père que l'on voit
ici comme au reste de la famille
la chasse a débuté depuis deux ans déjà
les services sont en alerte
à lui seul le dossier français
volumineux peu à peu les recherches vont
montrer qu'un même un peu se cacher
derrière une série d'attentats les
bombes devant les journaux l'aurore
l'arche minutes et la maison de la radio
les grenades lancées au drugstore
saint-germain deux morts 34 blessés rue
toullier deux hommes du
contre-espionnage assassiné de même que
leur indique michel boucard bain et
surtout la prise d'otage de 70 personnes
à vienne
les onze plus importants ministres du
pétrole sont là vingt-quatre heures
après en quittant l'autriche carlos
salue chaleureusement ce qu'ils libèrent
il laisse derrière lui trois morts et
l'un de ses lieutenants hans joachim
klein grièvement blessé il a survécu
depuis vingt ans ils errent tels un
soldat perdu il s'est repenti
selon lui carlos fut sans pitié pour ses
victimes pendant l'opération deviennent
alors que l'homme était donc hors combat
carlos lee a vidé tout son chargeur dans
le corps c'était un massacre de la pure
frime
à son arrivée à alger carlos libère ces
derniers otages
cette fois il est filmé et photographié
sous toutes les coutures
c'est lui qui court sur le tarmac il
embauchera plusieurs dizaines de
millions de dollars
le mythe carlos est née après
l'opération de décembre 75
carlos est plus que jamais dans la ligne
de mire des services aideront doux en
particulier il accumule des
renseignements sur les trafics de faux
papiers
les empreintes digitales du terroriste
l'information circule carlos agace ceux
dont il se revendique
les balles et signa les extrémistes
comme georges habache et en particulier
wadie haddad celui qui l'avait recruté
le lâche carlos le fedayin devient un
mercenaire la traque se poursuit pour
carlos les sanctuaires sont épisodiques
un peu partout dans le monde
au proche orient à l'est budapest
bucarest son ultime défi faire libérer
sa future épouse est un compagnon
d'armes arrêté en 82 en france
nouvelle succession d'attentats contre
le capitole 5 morts soit 117 blessés rue
marbeuf un mort 63 blessés ultime étape
khartoum au soudan depuis plusieurs mois
rondeau suis leur prêter carlos paz a
pas jusque dans ces réjouissances
nocturne
15 août 94 rondeau enlève carlos et le
livre à la justice
la traque au ras du ray au cours des
trois décennies
elle se sera déroulé sous 3 présidence
de la république jusqu'à son terme
aujourd'hui qui est des termes
judiciaires et avec toujours à sa tête
un seul et même homme
rondeau l'absolu contraire de carlos lui
il fuit tout renommée médiatique